oh hey guys this is Inka so I'm going to
be trying to make some super creamy
whipped coffee today using only three
ingredients and none of them will be
dairy products I am super excited about
this because I've been seeing this
amazing coffee pop up all over Instagram
and YouTube it's basically this like
beautiful smooth and silky cream like
coffee apparently this blew up in South
Korea they call it how to go on a coffee
the word actually comes from the street
food snack they have this toffee like
candy the batter is very similar to how
this coffee tastes and looks that's why
they named it so whipped coffee and
itself has actually been around for a
long time so really popular in places
like India and Macau that now it is a
internet craze they a so today I am
going to make my very own whipped coffee
at home so in terms of ingredients like
I said there's only three things and I'm
pretty sure everybody has this in their
pantry the first thing is instant coffee
brand itself doesn't matter but what's
really important is that it has to be
instant coffee there is a scientific
explanation for it I believe that has
something to do with stabilizing the
phone some sugar and also some water so
the best thing is you only need two
tablespoons of each ingredient if you're
only making this as a drink so if you
guys have this at home I think it'd be
really fun for us so I'll do this
together if you want to go grab those
ingredients now I am going to put them
all in the bowl here and we can start
mixing I'm going to start off with the
coffee
which smells so amazing now for sugar
last but not least some water it smells
so good so now that we have our
beautiful coffee mixture it is time for
whisking if you have a stand mixer
definitely feel free to just toss it in
and let it do all the work because
that's probably only gonna take three
minutes and you'll have that beautiful
meringue like coffee cream but for
today's purposes and because I really
want to test out the theory of like
having to mix it 400 times before you
can get that cream light consistency I
am going to go with a handless this will
be my workout for the day I hope you're
all ready for this and I hope you're all
doing this with me I'm actually also
going to start this timer and let's do
it
[Applause]
all right so it's been a minute and
right now it's kind of frothy looking
Tara this is what it looks like right
now I know we're so far from getting it
to that really meringue light
consistency but let's promise things
apart when I say it's been like almost
four minutes
and I have already with this 400 times
and my art I keep on searching my arms
because it's already so tired it's not
as liquidy as we started out with it
slightly foamy we have a long way to go
so I'm gonna start the timer again and
keep counting and yeah let's uh let's
finish this feel like my stand mixer is
mocking me hard work makes it taste
better
my readers asked me if I was pissed off
at something no I'm just trying to get
my coffee cream all right seven minutes
right now and there's a little bit more
of a body to it you don't you got I am
starting to sweat whoo
nine minutes in and I am sweating but
we're getting with these beautiful
ribbons I don't know how long how much
longer is it gonna go but it's been
almost 10 minutes now peanut butter it
looks like peanut butter
whoa we're getting there super exciting
news because it can't cling to my whisk
but I do want mine to have a little more
shape so I am going to go in a little
bit more it has been 13 minutes and 30
seconds and so I'm gonna see if we can
aim for 15 it smells so good in here
[Music]
whoa look at that look at this oh my
goodness Wow you guys I think it's
pretty much done look at this beautiful
soft peaks oh my god I am so excited
it's crazy because we really just
started out with this like liquidy brown
mixture and now it is this beautiful
cream like consistency it blows my mind
I could stare at this footage forever
there's some bull Wonka stuff it has
been around 17 minutes and this is the
beauty we have look at this I really
want to try it like this first before we
put it on anything else
Oh oh my god it is so light it literally
feels the exact way you would expect it
to I mean look at that it is so
perfectly smooth and rounded oh my god
that's really good
it is super caffeinated right off the
bat strong overwhelming coffee flavor
but the texture is so light and fluffy
all that airy we just put into it you
taste it
this is dangerous because you could
totally eat this like this and then be
like super energized for the rest of the
day okay so now that our whipped coffee
is done I am going to serve mine on a
glass of milk there's like a couple ways
you can do this you can use it as
frosting too but I would really enjoy it
cup of coffee right now so we're gonna
go with that I have my milk we're gonna
go ahead and pour this in
I think that should be enough now for
our coffee oh my God look at this
[Music]
did you guys see that oh my god it looks
so good oh this is the most satisfying
thing I have ever seen
[Music]
oh goodness
you guys tell me this isn't the most
perfect cup of coffee you've ever seen
gorgeous it is gorgeous this is honestly
so worth it I hope you guys as you were
following along are also at this place I
think you're supposed to mix it but I'm
gonna try and drink it like this first
little too dense all right let's mix it
I could stare at this number
[Music]
I'm ready it's a little more
incorporated now the milk has changed
color this is incredible
whoa to the people who've been doing
this for a long time you guys really
know what's up because this is an
incredible cup of coffee I always
thought that like you could only get
coffee this creamy if you have like you
know like a fancy expresso machine where
they can steam the milk for you but this
or the coffee itself is the frothy part
also I was expecting it to be a slightly
grainy but I think we really like went
in there and like whipped the heck out
of it
so everything that's left is pure
creaminess which is a beautiful thing if
there's ever a trendy thing that you
need to try and do at home this is it
remember this whipped coffee actually
has no cream whatsoever just to show you
guys that like you can enjoy this
without milk I'm actually going to use a
little bit of what I have leftover and
make it into like a little cup of coffee
[Music]
okay so this version only has water with
our lift coffee looks a little bit like
beer but it's super super frothy on top
we're gonna give it a try
this is still really good it's a lot
less creamy than the other one it's
still very very pleasant and you still
get that airiness on top I am going to
be drinking this for the rest of the day
and possibly the rest of the week and
the rest of the month because it is so
so good I hope you guys are enjoying
this too and I'll see you guys next time
for when we make our next trendy thing
Cheers
[Music]